the most terrible events in the history of
mankind took place when he was
faced with something unknown
frightening today in the south of the capital you can
observe this rare cosmic phenomenon,
not that I'm hurrying you, just
next time the stars will be under fifty years,
probably the
factories dense layers of your lobby will
come to admire the water
truly bewitching
people for thousands of years have been waiting for contact with
an alien civilization half an hour ago,
enough
went into what your object interfered with,
it depends on how they
behave further
weapons, but do you think why they flew in,
we have no idea what moral norms of
preemption to explain to them for a long time because  that
this is a unique chance for all of
humanity to understand something about ourselves,
to find out who we will all die and they, we
understand do not be afraid
if you do not want to go down in history, as if
we provoke an explosion, then there
may be no history at all, as you show, there may not
be anyone we attack
it  our earth
is important to earth
and another galaxy  and we with features
[music] the
attention of world agencies at this moment is
riveted to the events in the south of moscow
half an hour ago in the metropolitan area a completely
recognizable object
city martial law has been instituted the
street is closed to traffic
local residents have been evacuated, however,
many refused to leave, I remind you that the
victims of the incident were  232
dozens of people are reported missing in
hospitals more than 500 wounded remain I
don’t like what’s happening I don’t like anyone,
we just don’t do anything and
what options do we have we can dump
where we can’t stand it all we can
say this is our land this is our
land
and
I have all
[music]
today in the south of the capital you can observe a
rare cosmic phenomenon for the ambassador
object moves our installation is controlled
I don’t take it wants hearts willingness to
use
[music]
from
I
[music]
dignity
and you are completely sand  video
[music]